y los sonidos de una clase que llega con
lleno de posibilidad antes de que entren
los estudiantes el rumor de las ideas
que van y vienen a medida que exploramos
juntos del mundo las risas y los
pequeños son momentos de sorpresa que
encontramos en las cosas de las que
hablamos millones de veces cuando enseñe
inglés aquí en esta escuela pasaron a mi
verano preparándome para el año quiero
empezar lleno de anticipación
pero este silencio es algo pesado se
puede escuchar la ansiedad y su eco en
los pasillos vacíos
no hay un olor a nuevos cuadernos ni a
pisos limpios
aquí habría esos niños y ahora lo único
que se ven son las cajas en computadores
y lo escucho de tantos de ustedes la
frustración de los padres que tienen que
trabajar mientras apoyan el aprendizaje
de sus hijos tienen miedo de que sus
niños se enfermen la preocupación es de
todos aquellos que trabajan sin
suficiente protección la desesperación
en las filas en frente de los bancos de
alimentos y el dolor que no se puede
describir que sigue después de cada
último respiro cuando apagan un
ventilador como madre y como abuela como
estadounidense se me rompe el corazón
por la magnitud de estas pérdidas por el
fracaso de proteger a nuestras
comunidades
y vida perdida que es irreemplazable
como tantos de ustedes me quedo
preguntándome si como mantengo segura a
mi familia ser madre
llego a mi de una manera que nunca
experiencia yo me enamoré de un hombre y
dos niños pequeños que habían acabado
pasar por una pérdida terrible habían
perdido a su madre ya su hermana nunca
me imaginé a la edad de 26 me estaría
preguntando a mí misma
como unes a una familia de nuevo yo
siempre le dijo a los niños
mamá nos envió ayer y cómo podría yo
pelear con ella entonces lo logramos
juntos en esos grandes momentos que
pasan a veces muy rápido en 2 times
giving y en los cumpleaños y en las
bodas en dos citas mundanas que le dan
forma a nuestras vidas con esas
historias que nos contábamos los fines
de semana en la sala escuchando los
sonidos de las risas que flotaban de
arriba hacia abajo en la casa a medida
que yo ponía a los niños en la cama cada
noche mientras que yo estudiaba para
debajo de una lámpara de la cocina
encontramos que el amor une a las
familias el amor nos hace flexibles y
resistentes nos permite ser más que
nosotros mismos juntos y aunque no puede
protegernos de los dolores de la vida
puede darnos un refugio un hogar como
creamos de nuevo y completamos a una
familia de la misma manera cómo se hace
cómo se crea una nación con amor y
entendimiento con pequeños actos de
bondad con una fe inquebrantable
cuidando los unos a otros de pequeñas y
grandes formas
una y otra vez es lo que tantos de
ustedes están haciendo justo ahora por
sus seres queridos por personas que no
conocen siquiera por sus comunidades
aquellos hay algunos que quieren
decirnos que este país está dividido y
que nuestras diferencias no se puede
reconciliar pero eso no es lo que yo he
visto en los últimos meses
nos estamos uniendo y tomando los unos a
otros
encontrando la gracia y la piedad en
estos momentos que muchos dan por
sentado hemos visto que las diferencias
son preciosas y nuestras igualdades
infinitas hemos demostrado que el
corazón de esta nación aún está latiendo
con coraje y ese es el alma que joe
biden por la cual yo vaya de estar
luchando ahora
después de que murió nuestro hijo pau
del cáncer yo me preguntaba si realmente
iba a sentir alegría o iba a sonreír de
nuevo fue un verano
pero no quedaba ya calor para mí cuatro
días después del funeral de bon jovi joe
afectándose imponiéndose su traje lo vi
frente al espejo respirando
y caminar de nuevo es el mundo que ya no
tenía nuestro hijo el regreso al trabajo
y eso es lo que él es hay momentos en
donde yo ni siquiera podido imaginar
cómo podía hacerlo como ponía un pie
enfrente del otro y seguía avanzando
pero siempre comprendí por qué lo hacía
lo hacía por la hija que con vince
convence a su hija de finalmente hacerse
un examen de cáncer de seno y la lleva a
la clínica por el estudiante que ha
sobrevivido al abuso pero que encuentra
el coraje para terminar su carrera y
crear una buena vida para sus hijos lo
hace por el niño pequeño cuya madre está
sirviendo como marín en irak
la llama y no se queda cuando lo único
que quiere para su cumpleaños es estar
con ella para todos aquellos a quien yo
da su número personal en los eventos y
con los que habla durante horas después
de la cena ayudándoles a sonreír después
de sus pérdidas sabiendo o haciéndoles
saber que no están solos lo hace por
ustedes
el propósito de joe siempre ha sido lo
que lo ha impulsado avanzar su fortaleza
es algo que no se puede detener y su fe
es inquebrantable porque no somos los
partidos políticos o los políticos como
tal o es algo que está en él está en la
providencia de dios su fe está en
ustedes en nosotros
si tantas clases ahora están en silencio
los jardines aún están ahí pero si se
escucha de cerca se puede escuchar el
cambio en todo el país los educadores
los padres los trabajadores de
emergencias personas de todos los
orígenes están luchando unos por otros
nosotros no nos hemos rendido
simplemente necesitamos el liderazgo
digno de este país un liderazgo digno de
ustedes un liderazgo honesto que nos
unan nuevamente que nos ayude a
recuperar de esta pandemia y nos ayuda a
preparar para lo que pueda venir en el
futuro liderazgo que realmente nos ayude
a re imaginar cómo será esta nación es
ese es joe el ica moda van a trabajar
tan duro como ustedes todos los días
para hacer que esta nación sea mejor y
si yo tengo el honor de servir como su
primera dama lo haré igualmente y con
joe como presidente estas clases van a
llenarse de risas y de posibilidades
nuevamente los pesos que llevamos en
este momento son muchos pero necesitamos
alguien con hombros fuertes yo sé que si
confiamos esta nación a joe él va a ser
por sus familias lo que dijo por el blog
por lo que hizo por la nuestra
unirnos
y hacernos completos de nuevo llevarnos
hacia el futuro en este momento de
necesidad manteniendo la promesa de eeuu
para todos nosotros